cherry blossom season has arrived and so
have the crowds
gone are the barriers to prevent groups
from gathering there are no park
employees reminding people to maintain
physical distancing
south korea is still reporting high
number of new cases with a daily average
of more than 160 000 in the last week
but the government has announced it will
lift all physical distancing rules from
next monday
19 will not be completely over but we
are now judging that it is the time to
carefully try to restore our daily life
again people will still be required to
wear masks indoors and outdoors although
the government has said it will review
this in the weeks ahead
i think it's still appropriate to wear a
mask indoors but i think it's okay
without one outdoors if people are
keeping a distance
south korea was one of the first
countries to experience a covet 19
outbreak but it was able to flatten the
curve quickly with a combination of
testing tracing and treating
because of that it never had to impose
any lockdowns
public health officials were also quick
to revise their strategy when the highly
transmissible omicron variant took hold
we transitioned to a system for a large
scale outbreak placing more importance
on a universal approach under the
ordinary system while raising the
vaccination rate and administering oral
treatment
south korea is seen as a success in
terms of how it's handling the pandemic
even so officials have not let their
guard down the health ministry is
offering a second booster shot of the
coronavirus vaccine to people aged 60
and above
the who has recently warned the
coronavirus is far from becoming an
endemic disease and could still trigger
outbreaks around the world
florence louis al jazeera seoul